you know I made these plans nine months
ago whole reason I play the come on this
trip was whispers to find the secret
beach
not too many gringos here yeah mama
necesarios
is this the one see
gracias Senor Ian no no no por favor no
please please I don't know we were going
in the same way I live close by so don't
worry
are you sure yes are you getting out
from here
uber please away never mind
Thank You Carlos thank you again for
taking me here we nothing
siempre
you saying that you should come over
here
that way French better I'm okay I'm okay
I'm cool here thank you
careful green dot I think I'll be
alright
you come over here I'm good here thank
you
you
hey says hey I just want to let you know
I made it here mom was right it took
forever to find but it's perfect
what did you say the name of this place
was is it's paradise
yeah
I'm not dying here
30 40 yards it takes some 32 seconds
you
learning to be self-reliant takes time
and hard work these are the steps fill
responsibilities know where you are
going make your own decisions
yes sir it's hard works become
self-reliant any one of us could use a
bit more than we have if you're not
self-reliant you'll never do any more
than just get by
little dose of self-reliance can do
wonders now you may think that's the end
of the story actually it's only the
beginning hey Dad I made it here I'm
gonna catch one last one mom was right
it's perfect
the shallow-rooted 2:30 what did you say
her name in this place was this is
paradise
hi it's rising 40 yards
the shallows
and we did EG 13